we learned yesterday that jared kushner
and ivanka trump
earned somewhere between 172 million
dollars
and 640 million dollars in what is
called outside
income while working in the white house
during the presidency of donald trump
this was a financial analysis done by
crew
citizens for a responsibility and ethics
in washington i i forget exactly what
crew stands for
they looked at financial disclosures and
uh you might remember that
donald trump famously said he would
donate a salary and jared kushner would
be an
unpaid adviser to trump and ivanka would
be an unpaid advisor should no none of
them were taking salaries while working
for the government
and that was supposed to prove there's
no nepotism and there's no concerns or
whatever
and of course they continued to make
massive amounts of money from their
stakes for example ivanka trump's stake
in trump's hotel in dc which was
frequented and patronized by uh
world leaders and diplomats in order to
ingratiate themselves
with donald trump we saw all sorts of
ivanka's businesses including related to
i think it was handbags and whatever
else even sometimes promoted
on national television by paid advisor
to trump kellyanne conway
we saw all of it and they made an insane
amount of money
while working in the white house
advising a sitting president but
but but what about hunter biden right i
thought that was the issue
imagine making as much as
two-thirds of a billion dollars over
four years
while working a government job at the
highest level
now in reality family should simply be
banned from serving
in any position whatsoever for the
federal government
when a family member is president at
minimum
no matter what you're doing you should
have to be senate confirmed
now this is of course uh in addition to
the fact that they cost the american
people and taxpayers way more
money ivanka and jared through their
constant trips
secret service protection and the whole
thing so
yeah it's truly shocking you might
remember
and we're already seeing a lot of
responses about this people saying well
look
the clintons became super wealthy after
bill clinton was president barack obama
became super wealthy
after he was president yes that's after
after they weren't making millions and
hun
hundreds of millions of dollars during
their white house years and you know
this is a reality yeah bernie's a
millionaire he's also almost 80.
uh and at this point if if you've been
making you know six figures
for 30 years uh unless you're really bad
with money you would be a millionaire
uh presidents end up making a lot of
money because people hire them for
speeches
after they're out of office they get a
cushy book deal
but this isn't even the president this
is the president's kids while working
at the white house making somewhere
between 172 million
and 640 million dollars
um so you can't really what about your
way
out of that one now meanwhile
we don't really know what the future is
of many of these trump businesses
a lot of the trump real estate holdings
losing value
over the last four years half the
country
close to half the country won't even go
to trump hotels anymore for political
reasons and we know the dc hotel is
struggling and a lot of these
others are struggling that is all true
but it doesn't mean that these four
years weren't
extremely profitable for this family and
so
when trump said he would drain the swamp
um
he obviously didn't do it but the
personal
uh incomes of these individuals while he
was in office are
absolutely and completely stunning so
they're all going to be fine you know
some people
feeling bad that jared and ivanka aren't
welcome back in the social circles in
manhattan where they
previously uh uh were regulars don't
feel bad for them they're going to be
fine
they were able to work high-profile
government jobs i know they didn't have
a salary i know
continue making hundreds of millions of
dollars and
they they are going to do just fine and
they did much of it on the backs of
taxpayer dollars that's the reality
uh we will take a quick break the trump
impeachment trial number two
starts today we'll be covering it live i
have fox clips coming up i have
voicemails coming up and so many more
things
glad you're with me today